And oh again, welcome to this week's series and
The gut that's what we're talking about leaky got said room part two. Oh, it isn't this exciting
Well, it is for me because this is really where it all starts and how you are really going to heal
So this week we're gonna get a little bit deeper last week. We talked about the causes remember we said drugs are a major piece of this
foods
Like a glee added, which is gluten, GMOs, huge killer
It just are typical American diet that that has got to change all the processed additives,
Colouries, preservatives, chemicals,
Heavy metals that were consumed on a daily basis that our ancestors never consumed
We're exposed to more chemicals on a daily basis. It's just unbelievable next week
We're gonna get into toxicity and it's just it's
It's just really sad. We've just
Kind of destroyed our world in many ways
We said that there's test heat available. That's available. You could actually order some the Syrex test and some of the Chidolva tests
from our
Store if you do want to go that way
Sometimes tested is beneficial, especially for sensitivity's
Wed a child has to go to school and you have to say okay, we have to stay off gluten and you need that
document did
In order for some in force but to take place it also helps with
Children where parents might have some disagreements of whether
or not, you know, there's there's full support at home. So
Anytime's tested is is necessary we do it a lot less than we used to in the office
Because I could rely on
Can easily I'll let you test it in my office and remember take that and test it up for the ability that they can got tests that we created for you
At the my hope online website so
How are we gonna heal this?
Well in healing everything remember this is my huge thing here is we got to find out why we got to remove the cause
So when we talk about removing the cause is
Some of the other testing that we're going to talk about so look at our
two and finally we're going to talk about our three diets that
Our trademark diets the my
Eated diet and the my coveted diet is a good place to start again the my eated diet look at the information on the
my nutrition
section of
Our program about you diet is a plant-based diet the my coveted diet is a diet that is not plant-based
So not plant-based alone, but both of them start with the basis the first step of eating a whole food diet and
That as you go through both
Climb up the melted of both of these diets. You are eliminating different foods and
So this could all be done without the expense of detailed testing
You don't need to do
gluten-tested and other antibody testing in food testing that could get quite costly
That's just honestly just not necessary. You could make some assumptions and make some trials
You just don't want to make the mistake of thinking that it's gonna, you know
The changes are gonna take place overnight
If you have the cause of one of the causes of your leaky gut
Let's say gluten. We're gonna get into this a depth later, but if gluten is the cause of my leaky gut
I've had patients that come and say yes
I tried going gluten free for three months or six months or three weeks, so it just didn't seem to make the difference
Well, if you have antibodies to a peptide of gliadid or
the entire gliadid
Protein molecule those antibodies are gonna stay in your system for years
So going at gluten free or going dairy free for a week or two weeks is you many times will notice very little different so
We go through that with the diets, so just follow that a lot
But always when you're healing the gut it starts with what you're putting in there
So you can't be putting bad stuff in there and thinking that you're gonna heal it with the next steps that we're gonna talk about
It can't be eating McDonald's every day and then think that you're gonna build up the walls with a good
Nutrient pill or something like that just doesn't work that way
Secondly, we want to rebuild the walls with
the dietary changes that step up
Into the coveted in the neomia diet
Ultimately our peak diet is termed the neomia diet and again
We named it the neomia diet because
Biblically the prophet neomia was sent back to Jerusalem to rebuild the walls of
Jerusalem so that
God's coveted people could go home to Jerusalem
There's no way that they could go home with all the walls completely destroyed
From their exile so neomia was sent to rebuild the walls
We thought oh, that's a perfect name for exactly what we need to do in the gut rebuild that barrier
Head of the brain rebuild that barrier in order for a person to achieve health
There's so many so many likes in the Bible that just point us back to exactly what we're supposed to do
We also like to rebuild the walls with very specific nutrients. I'm not gonna go through all these in detail
But glutamine, aloe, corseted, our three
Huge ones that work very well modified citrus pectin works very well
Likrosch root works very well slick slippery elm works very well
You could also use something called PRP's
Proled-rich peptides that have found some great research and
Decreasing inflammation of the gut and allowing those cells to reheal
Now again, none of these are gonna work if you're gonna continue to eat McDonald's
It's just not gonna work that way you're gonna be fighting it in this battle
But they can still help so if I'm still on a medication that's damaging my gut and I can't get off that medication for
One reason or another
You adding these nutrients to your diet. Maybe they may have to be in a greater
Milligram source could be very helpful even if you can't get off some of those things
We use a product by designs for health called GI revive and or a product by Domenica called GI restore
There are some these are both in powder. They all they both come in capsule form to there's a number of other products on the market
Also, you could use that have those different nutrients in it
So you're certainly not limited to these two companies, but these are available in our store
We need to repopulate the gut as well with both pro and pre-biotics pre-biotics are things that can help
Probiotics can help the environment so that probiotics that means the macro nutrients the the macro
Biotic that is living symbiotically or quote-unquote is supposed to be living symbiotically in your gut
can
In fact live and they have a pot they have a
Good
Nutrient source for them to thrive
In this little picture there's some foods that are very high in
Prebiotics that that give a healthy gut source now
These are all in the eatings and coveted diet of the amyodine as well
The probiotics are adding different
Probiotic strains to your back to your diet now you could do this with
Fermented vegetables also, but we all don't get into that in depth and tell the the amyodine because there's some dangers
And just going to I'm gonna start eating a lot of fermented vegetables because I heard a lot about that
Well, they could be inflammatory as well and can spark a histamine reaction so you have to be careful about that
So I suggest that we start with probiotics different probiotics. These are three that we use from designs for health that are different strains
There are several other good probiotics. We actually have in our office
Multiple different strains of probiotics. I think there's a benefit to switching strains
So whatever straight you have if you have a probiotic at home use that and switch to a different company or a different
Strain within that company so that you're getting different strains. Remember there's a hundred million different
Symbiotic organisms that are living within your gut and just because you have 15 million or
Whatever eight strains that you're getting in a capsule
You we were just far from from where we need to be anyhow
So don't ever think that you you're doing everything with probiotics
There's more radical approaches that we use in our office for people that have very sick
Guts that is all sorts of colitis
Crohn's disease they need some more radical approaches and this has to do with the fecal transplant
So we're not going to get into that into this discussion because there's no way that we could do this and do it justice online
This is a whole discussion in itself, but I know it sounds horribly gross
But it could be just absolutely life-changing and life-giving
as an approach to getting that microbiota
Reestablished in a person from a donor's microbiota and
It just goes back to what you lose that
That symbiotic environment of those all those probiotic
Nutrients that are supposed to be in your gut. It just you know everything falls apart
We also use it in our office frequency heli
This is something that's also available through our store, too. We use the rife
This is the true rife machine that you see in this picture
But especially what you're dealing with viruses bacteria's other pathogens that are invading the gut
And that is one of the causes we talked about causes before we were mainly talking about chemical causes
in a later discussion we are going to talk about
biotoxic causes
And that is a huge issue with causing
leaky gut and and
Issue especially gram-negative bacteria
so
Many times the only way that you could kill them especially if the person is moved into an autoimmune situation where their
T.H. What dominant you can't give things that would normally kill a
bacteria kill a
Pathogen in the person's body, so you have to resort to frequency heli we've seen absolutely miracles
We've been using rife technology for 16 years now in our office and literally
People that should have died it didn't die and lived a long life
It's just miracle after miracle. So the person comes to us with live disease or
struggling with cancer it's you you can't be a member of our clinic without
Agreed to go home with a rife machine and you're using it on a nightly basis
So rife as she could be a
life-giving
Device for people with any type of biotoxid issues
lime issues H. Pylora issues and cancer
So don't overlook this piece especially if you're struggling with you've done many of these steps
As I know a lot of people in this program are going to be at a lot of different stages some this is all new to them
And they have to listen to this over and over again
But I'm trying not to go too slow or even speak too slowly because I know there's a lot of people and I've done
All this already and they're like I just I just need the next step. I just need one of my supposed to do
Well, this may be the step that you completely missed
So there's a number of different frequency heli tools out there
We solely use the true rife so
If you purchase it through our store it comes with my programs on it
You can certainly purchase it through my good true rife too. He's a wonderful guy. He just loves to help people so
Great thing don't overlook that
Healing the gut is also you have to look at decreasing stress
There's a number of both studies out there about putting a boss in a they experiments putting mice in stressful situations
And it just completely destroyed their gut flora. So
Now it's hard to do those studies
They haven't at least been flooded out of humans. Yeah, but I but you could they're pretty equivalent
Increasing stress decreases gut flora increases like you got issues. So
Doing things to decrease stress is essential. I'm not gonna talk about that much more and lastly
You got to remember that this is a process I
eluded earlier that
Taking something out of your diet or trying to make changes and thinking that you're gonna have this wonderful success in three to six weeks
It's sometimes happens, but many times it just doesn't you have to heal
So your intestinal cells reproduce a new cell about every 12 weeks
So you got to put yourself at least in its 12 weeks cycle when you're trying to do something you'd make changes
So it's just you just can't overcome
40 years of insult in in a quarter you know of a year and
Be realistic so understand that life's a process and there's just there's literally
Thousands and thousands of biochemical processes that are going on what you're making changes that that need to heal so
Give yourself some patience
Next week we're going to get into toxicity and some that biotoxins but chemical toxins that we may have to deal with
These are into causes here, and if we don't deal with these chemical toxicities
We could be chasing our tail too, so that's gonna be a great piece next week
So stay to know that make sure you take that test for a test of the permeability and any other quizzes that we have online this week too
All right, I will see you next week